let's go next to our caller from the 805
area code caller from 805 please say
hello tell us who you are and what's on
your mind today hello I'm Tony I'm
calling from Chicago great all right
Tony speak up as much as you can and
tell me what's on your mind my main
thing that I wanted to speak to you
about today was I well you know
obviously they were all talking about
the biggest shooting I have family in
Vegas but you know nobody got hurt
anyways I hear on the television
abundance and the Democratic senators
saying that we should all call our
congressmen and and you know go to the
offices and protest and do the same
thing we did with the health care team
but I'm wondering if that's gonna be
enough I mean the NRA is just so so
powerful yeah what do you think about
that NRA is hugely powerful you know the
crazy thing I was thinking about this
yesterday Pat after we did our NRA
related story the NRA should kind of if
the NRA were sketchy and they are why
wouldn't the NRA surreptitiously
encourage protests in favor of new gun
safety laws because the NRA during Obama
sold a ton of guns by telling everybody
Obama's gonna take your guns under Trump
not as many guns are being sold because
there isn't this narrative of trumps
coming for your guns
so the NRA should be if because the
remember the NRA is a gun lobby they
want to sell as many guns as possible
the NRA should quietly encourage
protests in favor of gun safety laws so
that then they can say look they're
trying to get Trump to take away your
guns
you better buy more guns right that is
especially because the NRA represents
gun manufacturers absolutely gun owners
if it was another group that represented
the owners maybe it wouldn't work but in
this case I think it could yeah so I
mean to answer your question Tony I
don't know what it will take to pass
basic gun safety laws if you look after
Sandy Hook with 85 or 90 percent
approval for 100% universal background
checks it didn't pass under Obama so if
we couldn't do that I don't see anything
getting done anytime
soon another thing I noticed is that the
media is incapable of juggling more you
know more than one story so that's
another thing that but you know I'm this
morning I already read solutions already
taking over the whole cycle it looks
like and I think the media is incapable
of keeping the story in the people's
mind say you know we see it on Twitter
and everything and all the everybody who
who is for them which is a majority of
us but another team that is discouraging
is to see the media that's not gonna be
able to follow through the whole story
really yeah yeah I can't count on
corporate want you to do that alright
Tony thanks very much appreciate the
call glad your family and friends in
Vegas are okay